was hier abläuft ich bin ganz ehrlich
geschwenkt und dann sieht aus wie hin
gepackt und hingeschmissen
bevor es losgeht kurze info das video
was sie gleich sehen werden habe ich mir
zunächst kamera aufgenommen und sogar
ein grund haben sie da die
seitenverhältnisse verstellte deswegen
alles wieder zum bisschen schwarze
balken am rand gleich aber dass ich
jetzt mehr lustig geworden ich will
jetzt nicht vorenthalten deswegen jetzt
viel spaß heute er sie konnten nur ein
video ich habe heute bekommen heutige
video münsterland mit der
professionellen stylisten hier an geholt
hier eine ausbildung im bonner alles
klar die ja häufig mal mädels hab ich's
sein
er werde nicht und dann werden wir sehen
was dabei rauskommt und ich werde mein
style entdecken mich als lustigen
bergkamen eigentlich auf die idee
wir haben müssen wir werden geschrieben
und dann meinte fest den er geschrieben
ich habe noch beratung brauchen die
beiden leute mit dem namen zählen
bestimmte paris
hörstück die kommission ist ich mache
von nächsten frauen arbeiten anders
hansen rabatt.de bis zum letzten moment
bin ich einfach so die kamera besitzen
videos
wie seid ihr hingekommen ist ja dass ich
habe keine zeiten vor sich hin zum thema
das über sein gespann gehören einfach
den mund hier ausweichen
das heißt wenn ich runter springen
gleich dann überlebenschancen sind nicht
perfekt doch die reaktion vom also der
stylist gott verdienen und was gott und
du bist
ich bin gespannt ob allende dass
menschen dann kurz model renaissance für
die kinder chips stunde
das ist ein einfacher mann gerne wenn
wir alle gehören die am samstag waren
alle schüler bestimmt wieder richtig
[Gelächter]
jetzt schon stunden über die jungs
deutschland aussehen dass nur noch 34
spachtel hinzu ich glaube ich darf
definitiv und jede müsst ihr noch mal
anderen namen des shipping überlegen
oder ja aber das ist nicht die geräusche
wahrgenommen
viele leute zivilgericht komplett online
facebook weiß nicht was das ist aber
concealer astronomisches ganz frisch
spiegel ja ich weiß was er an mir das
alles wieder am meisten bin ich heute
tatsächlich drei länder gespannt
bevor ich würde so eine ansage machen
möglichst echt gewaltig was ganz kurz
die leute sind jetzt geradeaus sehe ich
werde am ende sehen dich fertig aussehen
noch sehr gern am ende des weges manager
und jetzt ja hätte jemand die so forsch
bewertet also vonnöten ist kompletter
direkt bevor ich habe die aufgabe nicht
ernst ganz las vegas ausgesagt wurde vor
jede sparkasse
[Musik]
ein rausch hätten seinen ecken trachten
dass man der channel
ich musste eigentlich finden die hübsche
auf der seite dass hier ab leute ich bin
natürlich geschminkt und dann sieht aus
wie ihn gepackt und hingeschmissen paket
würdest du es so flach legen möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen
aber es ist echt sein denkt sich so ja
ok wusste nicht dass wir uns da nicht
machen und dann ist fertig und denkst du
weißt dass ich meine dass auch wenn ich
ein video vielen dank an meine stylistin
ja ein super job gemacht nicht
dankeschön
die leute waren völlig oben könnte auch
mal ein stein kostet ein apfel pause
aufwärts pro tag dann ein abstecher
lernt